se volete vedere come sono diventato una
zucca sorrido zza continuato a guardare
questo video
ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi ho deciso
di fare un qualcosa che in italia
diciamo non è che vada tantissimo di
moda o almeno non tanto quanto va in
alcune parti del mondo tipo america
londra e altri paesi anglosassoni ma
abbiamo deciso di intagliare una zucca
di halloween sia perché mi diverte un
sacco e sia perché fondamentalmente
questo non dovremmo cucinare quindi
teoricamente i danni dovrebbero essere
abbastanza contenuti si spera dubito
in passato ho fatto altre zucche di
halloween sono tutte quante venuti una
merda sempre una quindi una certezza o
sta lavorando adesso ad alcuni pattern
non so se riceve a vederli ma nessuno di
questi mi soddisfa ancora non ho capito
se voglio infilarle questa nell in bocca
alla zucca perché si sa una mela
infilarla prove metterla così capita
utilizzare questo cosino qui per il naso
e fare un qualcosa di un pochino diverso
dalla tipica zucca con gli occhi
sgranati e il sorriso cattivo è questo
qui sembra un pomodoro famoso pomodoro
di halloween
un'idea che ci piaccia joker zucca con a
giocare zucca maiolo naso la bocca
non sono riuscite a far la pace con la
mia bocca una zucca sempre di un'amica
biancaneve ok non il cazzo se è vitato
per fortuna è tornato è tornato il
malanno anziché non ci ha lasciato
nostre non solo questa è la parte
frontale o questa se non è più
interessante questa qui sembra più ma
non è che ti faccio qui non stavo
disegno di fare questo grazie gianni
questo pennarello indelebile
secondo el abbiamo iniziato perché cos'è
questo pennarello se questo dentro un
occhio e questo diventa un occhio ora
noi stiamo cercando di salvare un errore
che ho fatto così non c'è spazio per la
mira è carino lamela non c'entra io
stamen sa già bene vi dico io direi di
iniziare il signor tod's
come infatti ero a casa ragazzi
sarà un fallimento stiamo di un
fallimento come cavolo fanno ad aprire
queste teste richiamo slater che si sta
alzando
ok guarda qui
mamma mia non ti piace quest'anno la
fortuna c'è quante della chiesa un botto
quanto te iniziamo intagliati cantini
sto sashimi di zucca si rendono ok qui
sto andando proprio freestyle weiler
moglie ea fatto tutti che si perde
qualcuno senza gialle variano rimane un
bambino di un anno
amiamo ito ago tutti i denti il vecchio
fino come i tennisti non è un dente non
è un dente io andrò a dormire questa
notte in sei stato è stata un dente
ragazzi alla ci sta il naso a sto punto
uno snuff stai cominciando ad
appassionati o no
oddio svegli di riferire kakà
[Musica]
un pochino ce lo siamo perche per me
ancora in circolazione un occhio se n'è
andato e anzi ma pure più paura è morto
mentre io grandi successi e poi la
domanda è quanto duro la zucca fuori dal
frigo per sempre allora ragazzi non
vedere come che vengono naturali la
polizia di denti non si può fare la
torta di imbalsamazione imbalsamare una
giocabile mar comitini tiri fuori delle
tecniche si spappola diventa un bullone
questi occhi sono il vero problema
ragazze io vado a casa o in tagliando i
contorni poi entrò al coltello e via
strappo io dico di sì bravo ma a me
semmai porti più spia che capiva uno è
un salto e qualcosa
marco sembra che stava operando ancora
aperto e guarda questi rughe funzionano
così a occhio fanno gare in camera
sembra una roba pazzesca davvero oggi
con una macchina finisse per guardare
dall'allievo ma per fare perdere quindi
stiamo distorcendo la realtà come
internet fa da danni ormai infatti
guarda lì ieri macchia spazi per la mera
ma dove ammette enrico non ce la faccio
più di non sentire questo di zucca
facciamo che toto costil etico e affini
di dovuto mettere la mia dentro la buca
ok mi tocco stilistico quando metto la
mena nella zucca è finita
pochissimo le mie due mete una vela come
orecchio siete mazzone milano replica no
io per il contorno occhi questa zucca
sto prendendo ispirazione dal riflessa
allo specchio la mattina un anti aging
non ti farebbe male facciamo entrare di
più gli occhi e qui rischiamo di fare
danno oddio danno no gli elevato
l'occhio si staccavano ragazzo che c'è
con quali di tutte se sta a capire
questo ne vogliono sentire glielo diamo
il faticoso per fare qualcosa di carlo è
brutto cosa di fare ora scusa dei vari
temi della pena
le varie todd definitivamente grazie a
dami versino proprio bisogno di perdere
un pochino di diottrie con quella luce
puntata nella cornea dimenticato
completamente esiste questa macchina non
sto riuscendo più a parlare a fare
niente un incappato affari tutorial con
i denti per vedere il toro
ecco nel piano casa che i carichi ma
perché sempre negativi anche con
bellissima siamo chi è che kakà
zucchetti giorni e poi manca il tocco
finale s.fiore essi il tocco di mano
non a me l'ha detto emesso una volta si
e ti rende il giusto per il gusto di
torino quale gli tolgono questo non ci
credo perché sullo stesso livello culto
quando vuole mangiare il nostro caro e
voi dovete un'amica di mia madre
la vuole divorare non saprò perché la
odia il punto in uno dei nessuno solo
lei la odia
eppure una signora buonissima è cambiato
che cosa è cambiato
questo lo sfondo durava tipo 7 ore e
questo la dice lunga
basta basta basta questa è la zucca
finale
io dico niente proprio allora vogliamo
fare l'esperimento ragazzi in tanto e
facciamo pulizia che ricordo di
iscrivervi al canale se vi fa piacere a
me farebbe molto piacere attivare la
campanella delle notifiche e inoltre
metterci un bel pollice in su per il
qualora vi fosse piaciuta questa zucca
ma anche qualora la odia così per per lo
sforzo e fateci sapere soprattutto qual
è il vostro voto da 1 a 10 dove 1 è
imbarazzante e 10 10 e michelangelo chi
sentirà angelo che tirava folgora tutta
la mia quante zucchero ha fatto un gran
gelo
io le do 7 siamo d'accordo 7 nino le
provava accende così chiaramente va bene
lo sciocco ecco spegnere le luci
abbassate
vendola stasera non vieni vai dai cari e
carina è carina e bellissima cosa nota a
tutti che si è spostato tutto qui se
spostavano tutto scusava quello statico
da quanto è in campo non lo so ho fatto
ragazzi stiamo facendo un casino quindi
voto finale 7 al buio e a 887 e mezzo
globale al buio è il buio più al buio
più luce sette e mezzo ma non era 88 al
buio 7 da quindi in totale 1 nei sette
mesi
funziona così io preferivo 7 meno ciao